uh of course uh the met office doesn't
issue these red warnings lightly can you
put it into real terms for people in
terms of just how serious this is
thanks very much yes good morning to you
uh yeah these are rare we changed the
warning system to be more impact-based
in 2011 and we've only issued 15 or 16
of these red weather warnings so they
are rare and it's very rare to have two
out at the same time
this is the first time we've ever issued
a red warning since we changed the
system
for london and the south east so we only
issue them when there is a threat to
life from the weather so we are
particularly concerned from storm units
today there's two red weather warnings
the one in place already across the
south west the wind's continuing to
strengthen there in the next few hours
parts of south wales and southwest
england and then this second warning
coming into play at 10 o'clock this
morning until three o'clock this
afternoon across london and the
southeast and it's more the steady
nature of the winds likely across the
southeast as well it's unusual inlands
across southern england to see gusts of
60 to 70 miles an hour and that's what
we are expecting and it's gonna be a
couple of hours maybe two three four
hours of these kind of gusts of wind
that are likely to cause the damage
particularly across
the southeast corner so yes they are
rare this is a very serious issue we
have an amble warning covering most of
england and wales as well and again the
message even in that amber warning area
is please consider whether you really
need to travel today
uh now of course that uh red warning for
london and the south east was issued
overnight which comes in in around an
hour and a half if i'm not mistaken that
is the first time a red weather warning
has been issued
for london
what uh could that mean for the capital
yes we changed the way we issue warnings
back in 2011. and this is the first time
that we've issued one actually so fought
for london and the southeast so it is
rare
and it does mean there is a risk to life
obviously in london there's a lot of
bill there's a lot of scaffolding
there's a lot of cranes that kind of
thing and these kind of winds are
unusual right across the southern half
of england so and it's that sustained
nature of a few hours of the capital
getting battered by these very strong
dangerous winds likely to cause flying
debris likely to cause issues we've uh
given this warning uh a few days ago we
named this storm so we've we've named it
on monday so we've given plenty of
advice by advanced notice we you know we
named the storm that helps to raise
awareness of it as well so hopefully
people are taking heed of the warnings
that have been issued and yeah we
increased it to a red warning overnight
because we are now more confident that
we are expected to see
significant impacts across london and
the southeast through the late morning
into the early afternoon
of course the country has barely
recovered from storm dudley which hit on
wednesday
could it be that we see another storm
follow after this
it's not too unusual to see two storms
in a week what is unusual is for us to
name two storms on the same day we've
never done that before that's what we
did on monday to to flag these two
storms coming in wednesday and friday to
get to give people notice to let people
know to raise awareness that's the whole
point of why we name storms following on
behind there are more low pressure
systems the weather isn't showing signs
of calming down i must stress the
weekend doesn't look as stormy but
strong winds are still likely to cause
problems we do have a a warning in place
for saturday yellow warning
and partly part of that is of course
because these storms have come through
they may have weakened uh structures
weakened trees so even if eunice doesn't
bring down a tree today could have
weakened it enough so that a strong gust
over the weekend may then cause some
disruption so the weather isn't showing
signs of calming down too much it won't
be as stormy but we are expecting
further wet and windy spells on saturday
and sunday and even beyond that the
weather looks pretty disturbed for most
of next week